the new year is just two days away so
we're looking at the stories and trends
that will define the year to come in our
series what's new in 22. this morning
we're focusing on health especially the
coronavirus in 2021 more than 605
million coveted vaccines were given out
in the u.s also the fda authorized
emergency use of two new coveted
anti-viral pills chief medical
correspondent and the man with the
master plan dr john lapoop joins us
right now what to expect in 2022 in the
fight against covet john how are you
doing this morning
how you doing nate big hello this
morning i gave you a little too short
one the other day from vermont
i appreciate that thank you so much now
let's get right to it um how can these
anti-viral pills help with the fight
against covet
well this is kind of a big deal right
the pax pax levitt is from pfizer um and
malnu pyrivar there is from merck um
paxlavid decreased hospitalization and
death by
89 percent if given within three days
and 88 percent if given within five days
uh multnopera there uh was less
effective at about 30 but now these are
pills that you can take yourself at home
right now i've had a bunch of patients
who i've had to arrange for monoclonal
antibodies for for example and it's a
pain you've got to get them into a place
where they can get an intravenous
there's a whole procedure involved they
have to leave their home here think
about it if you have symptoms at the at
the beginning it's for people who are at
high risk of a bad outcome uh you can
just take it at home and we're hopefully
over time you might even extend this to
other populations less at risk
so you touched on it just a little bit
but who benefits most from this
treatment
you know it's right now it's for people
who are at high risk for a serious
outcome of you know hospitalization and
death people with underlying conditions
etc but um you know over time
remember tamiflu which you give with flu
symptoms either either if you have the
flu yourself uh or if you if you've been
exposed to it and imagine if it evolved
where it was effective and we see that
it's safe that it could be used like
that you know right now it'd be just
like another bullet you know that we can
use against this uh this virus
so john it's vlad uh so the fda has
authorized these two antiviral pills
when can they be made available to the
public
well um so far uh
it looks like they're gonna be tens of
thousands available before the end of
the year that's now of the pax levitt
hundreds of thousands in january and
then tens of millions throughout the
year
we're hearing that with uh monu piravir
which is the merck drug that millions of
them are expected to be available soon
so i got a notice from nyu langone
health where i'm a professor of medicine
that pax lavid was going to be uh soon
available um so
i think pretty soon the problem is going
to be vlad
is there enough initially to satisfy the
need you know we're going to have this
huge up and down hopefully down quickly
but we're seeing a big spike in cases
now and by the time we get enough pax
levit for example which is seems to be
more effective um you know we it may be
a little bit past that huge
spike that where we really need it
but it'll be
okay good good to hear um i saw my
friend's four-year-old who turns five in
two weeks and he's very excited to get
the vaccine he's very disappointed he
has not been able to get the vaccine
like his older brother
has kids under the age of five not
eligible right now do we think in 2022
we'll see authorization of a vaccine for
kids under five
you know jamie i'm we're hoping but you
know this is an example of where people
should be
happy that the fda is being so careful
the dose for the pfizer vaccine for
example is 30 micrograms the dose for
the kids under 5 is 3 micrograms they're
being very careful and what they found
was that there just wasn't enough of an
immune response with that dose they're
looking at a third modern is also still
recruiting so fingers crossed that in
2022 you'll see uh the the younger kids
get it too
all right dr john lupu we have to go so
real quick what have we learned in 2021
that we can take in 2022 that can
hopefully help us get over this hump
real quick what have we learned while
standing on one foot um well
i think we've learned that you know it's
not p i know it's it's depressing right
you know here we are it's another spike
it's another holiday season but i'm
actually cautiously optimistic because
one hypothesis is uh that what could
happen right now is we're going to see a
big spike up there's no doubt about that
hopefully with fewer hospitalizations uh
compared to previous versions of the of
the virus but still you're going to see
more hospitalizations you're going to
see deaths
but then hopefully if the big asterisk
if this does not mutate into a
worse variant we could see it come down
uh it's going to be a bumpy road but i'm
hoping that we're headed towards the off
ramp it could take a be a really rough
six to eight weeks uh and then after
that it could become endemic and then
drugs like pfizer's drug and and uh
mercs drug could be really really
helpful
sounds good dr john lepuc thank you so
much